former president donald trump's business
debt is estimated at 1.3 billion dollars
this is about 200 million dollars more
than when he left office even though
that's a large sum to o trump's balance
sheet is actually in better shape today
than it was months ago there is one key
explanation to this earlier this year
jpmorgan chase helped loan 1.2 billion
dollars against a san francisco office
complex in which trump holds a 30
percent minority interest
this helped trump and his business
partner vornado realty trust to pay back
their previous debt against the building
and extract about 616 million dollars in
cash that cash could come in handy over
the next few years next september trump
has a 100 million dollar loan due on the
commercial space inside trump tower two
months after that he'll have another
debt mature at another new york
skyscraper known as 1290 avenue of the
americas if he and vornado refinanced
that loan as well trump could walk away
with another 75 million dollars doing
that would also give him some breathing
room for 2023 when loans on his golf
resort in miami are due he'll also have
to think about his dc and chicago trump
hotels in 2024 when an estimated 215
million dollar loan from deutsche bank
is set to expire you could also look at
it this way the more cash trump can
stockpile now the safer his finances
will be in the future even if it means
increasing his debt position in the
meantime
you